foreign
Roger Penrose welcome back to how the
light gets in my pleasure
well you've been a friend of the II and
how the light gets in since its early
days so it's a great pleasure to have
you back a Nobel Prize winner now so
many congratulations on that important
recognition from us you spend much of
your career tackling questions that
touch on the foundations of physics and
the philosophical questions that arise
from some of them
how have you the attitudes changed
within the academic scientific Community
towards people like you who aren't
afraid to engage with both physics as
well as the philosophical questions that
arise from them
I think it's got more
acceptable in a way I'm not quite sure I
think uh there's one of the big issues I
think was Consciousness because it's
become
more acceptable as being a scientific
topic
whereas I think
you see I wrote the book The Emperor's
New mind
rather
not realizing that I wasn't supposed to
write books like that
Consciousness was something was it
wasn't a scientific topic I think
and that's become more allowed I guess
in a sense
would you say that Beyond Consciousness
at the deeper questions in physics end
up touching on these bigger questions
that sometimes belong to philosophy how
do you understand the relationship
between
philosophy and physics when it comes to
these foundational questions but I think
a lot of these things
I'm sure the
connection between philosophy and
physics is quite old
and probably
even before people knew much much about
physics it was really it was philosophy
so I don't know I'm not sure I would say
that's so new
I was only saying I think the
Consciousness thing is become part of
science
I don't think I could see that there's
more of a connection between physics and
philosophy
I mean there's some people who still
would take the view that
um
if you're just waffling about philosophy
then well I mean there is the question
of the collapse of the wave function
which I think maybe a lot of people
thought was philosophy
I don't know I tend you see I take the
view that it's genuine physics which you
don't yet understand
not that we just don't understand we
don't
not understanding rather implies that
the theories out there which we haven't
grasped and I think often people take
quantum mechanics in that sense they say
it's it's a mysterious subject and you
know it takes you're not you're not
going to be able to
understand it properly without
really realizing there's that deep
mystery in it
that's not the way I like to look at
this I tend to look at the problems in
quantum mechanics are really that we
don't
fully have the theory
that the collapse of the wave function
is a physical process
which needs to be understood properly
and there are experiments which probe
uh the nature of that area
so I'm trying to bring that thing more
into into the realm of physics rather
than as it might have been sort of
hovering around as the philosophical
issue
so let's let's talk about this topic of
Consciousness as you mentioned
traditionally was thought to be a purely
philosophical topic rather than a
scientific one but from the early days
of quantum mechanics there was this
interpretation that Consciousness had
something to do with the collapse of the
wave function that somehow consciousness
measurements involving a conscious
Observer was the thing that
made the wave function collapse from a
state of superposition yeah but you're
not very convinced by that well you see
I have almost the opposite of you I
think the terminology drove people in
that way it's like saying make an
observation
and when you made an observation you had
to change the rules
up to that point you take the
schrodumer equation is describing the
evolution of the
physical world and then when an
observation is made
it's only telling you the result of an
observation but then the observation was
really something outside physics
whereas The View I would take is that we
should be looking for a physical Theory
uh
which reduces the state
we don't have the physical Theory yet
although I think in my view it's going
to be something to do with how gravity
relates to quantum mechanics and that
when a system becomes big enough
for its gravitational fields to become
significant
then you have to bring it into account
and the measurement process
it's not really a measurement process
it's a collapse of the wave function
process which is actually something
which happens independent of how you
you only measure something because
you're tired you tie the system you're
observing into a bigger system which is
making the measurement and so you're
really looking at how that physical
system behaves as a whole
as you said your view on the
relationship between quantum mechanics
and Consciousness is almost the opposite
of this interpretation of the
measurement problem
can you tell us a little bit about your
view in your view
Consciousness in the brain arises out of
the collapse of the wave function can
you explain that puzzling claim what
does that mean exactly
well they're sort of reasoning behind
why I think that view if you like or I
can say more about what the view is I
mean the reasoning behind it
had to do with the issue of
it really came from my attendance of a
course of lectures given by a man called
Steen
in Oxford sorry in Cambridge when I was
a graduate student in Cambridge and I
went to three courses of lectures which
were nothing to do with the topic I was
supposed to be doing which was algebraic
geometry
and I went to a course by Bondi on
gender relativity which was certainly
very relevant to what I did later
uh lectures by Dirac on quantum
mechanics
where I did the puzzle of the collapse
of the wave function was became more
evident to me and of course on
mathematical logic by a man called Steen
and his lectures
made clear to me at least what seemed to
be clear to me but
conscious understanding
could not be an algorithmic process
there's something different
from computational
processes going on so if
we believe that whatever we are of May
we're sort of physical structures
then do we act according to
uh computational laws or is there
something in the laws of physics which
is outside that and the view I
maintained that time because of the
lectures students lectures on
mathematical logic and regardless
theorem
it seemed clear to me
that conscious understanding had to be
something which was not computational
and then the question is if it is a
physical process of some sort what could
that physics be and if I think about
classical Newtonian mechanics it didn't
seem to give you much chance
even gender relativity because you could
put these things on computers there is a
bit of an issue about the fact that
theories depend on continuous parameters
whereas computation as normally
understood is a discrete process
and the way we do calculations in
physics to mirror what's going on in the
world and put them on computers
we regard these as approximations which
you could refine as much as you like
and they're still then computational
processes there is a little bit of a
problem there
about whether there might be a distinct
difference in continuous Evolution from
discrete processes but I didn't think
that was the answer
seemed to me that there had to be
physical processes
which were not computational
and uh
the view is that this is conscious
understanding has to be one of these
and where in physics do we see anything
not computational or anything of
relevance that would be not
computational and uh
it seemed to me it had to be the
collapse of the wave function was the
physics of quantum mechanics and the
collapsible wave function specifically
non-computational comparison the rest of
the physics with the arguments really
the other way around it's not saying why
that's non-computational it's the
argument was if we need something
non-computational what could it be
that's the arguments that way around and
if it's just classical processes even
general relativity even if it's Quantum
with regard to following this
Schrodinger equation
I see nothing non-computational in that
because these things you could put on a
computer
so if there is something
non-computational it's got to be outside
any of those views and what is what has
a chance of being outside well
collapse the wave function so tomorrow a
process of seeing process of elimination
rather than
expecting to see it there so that was
your reasoning for thinking there was a
connection between Consciousness and the
collapse of the wave function yes now to
the understanding of how to think of
that how how do you think of this
phenomenon how do you see Consciousness
the collapse of the wave function how do
I see it
well I think that required a lot of
refinement as time went on and in fact
when I wrote the empress new mind
although I had the view that General
view I didn't have what I now believed
to be the right Criterion although I did
think it was gravitational
um the what I regard as being the right
criteria or at least towards being the
right criteria is um
dependent on an argument which I I can't
remember exactly when I first thought of
this argument but it's showing a an
incompatibility
between the principle of equivalence
between that is the
equivalence between a gravitational
uniform gravitational field and
acceleration so it's the Galileo
principle if you like you drop imagine a
big rock and a Little Rock leaning from
dropped from the Leaning Tower of Pisa
and they drop together let's go there
with clearly pointing out
and
that principle
is the basis of gender relativity
combined with special relativity if you
like you've got speed of light being
visited in with
being a constant of nature
and time and space being part of one
structure
of space-time
and then Einstein modifies that picture
by introducing the principle of
equivalence
and saying that gravity is not a force
it's uh
you can get rid of it by real falling
freely with it
however if the force is not uniform
mother
the gravitational
acceleration field is not uniform you're
led into a curved space time
now
the arguments that I was making
was that if you have a principle of
equivalents there are two ways of
looking at a
Quantum system in which you want to take
the Earth's gravitational field into
consideration
the way that any sensible physicist
would use when I say sensible and in
just the normal way
would be to do what's called putting the
term in the hamiltonian
you have your standard quantum
mechanical procedure and you accommodate
the Earth's gravitational field by
putting this extra term
in the hamiltonian
that's the Newtonian way of doing it if
you like you're thinking of
gravitationals
force is just another Force then you say
what's the understanding way of looking
at it well you say take the principle of
equivalent seriously and
falling free if if you have a uniform
gravitational field you can consider
describing that system with a coordinate
system which is dropping freely and then
there is no gravitational field
it's just using an acceleration frame
and then you compare the two procedures
and what you find is that they're almost
exactly the same but the key is in the
almost
the difference is in what's called a
phase Factor
and
the usual attitude in quantum mechanics
is to ignore the phase Factor you say
these two states are the same
so you could ignore it that's not quite
Fair because you look carefully at the
nature of this phase factor and you see
it involves the term
where the time comes in cubed
the gist of all this is that you are
doing a different Quantum field Theory
you have to know what the quantum vacuum
is in order to
do your Quantum field Theory properly
and the vacuum is different if you take
the Newtonian perspective and the
outstanding perspective again you might
say who cares
stick to your vacuum and you get a
consistent answer so why bother
this is all right as long as your field
is a constant field like the Earth's
gravitational field it's a bit like
going back to Galileo and say you can
get rid of gravity if you fall freely in
it
but it doesn't quite work if As you move
around the field is in a different
direction so it's all right to say you
can get rid of the field
vertically downwards here but what about
in
Tasmania or something you see it's a
different direction
so to hang together your theory where
these directions are moving
As you move around is a challenge
and what it leads you to is
um an inconsistency you can't greatly
quite do it
and so what you have to do is try and
estimate
the error involved in this
and that estimate gives you
you have to do a little bit of
mathematics and you see that that comes
to a sort of uncertainty and energy of
the system
and that uncertainty in the energy in
the system you can interpret is a
lifetime of the system this is going to
Heisenberg and you have this Heisenberg
time energy uncertainty so if you have
an energy uncertainty
that is related to a lifetime you get
this for for um particle physics for an
unstable nucleus
there is an energy uncertainty which is
inversely related to its lifetime so the
argument then this your Quantum
superposition which has this
tension in it which is an energy
uncertainty you can work out the
lifetime
so that lifetime
tells you how long a Quantum
superposition will last
that this actual formula I had was found
already by dyoshi another physicist who
some years before me had put that
forward
so it's sometimes called the Doshi
Penrose model
we the rest of the theory is not quite
the same he has a different way of
looking at things for me so they are
different theories really but the but
there's lifetime is the same criteria as
he had
now in in when I wrote the emperor's new
mind I didn't have that quite right
but having it when I say quote right I
didn't have the current view I have on
this
whereas in Shadows of the mind which is
the next book I wrote I put in what I
now believe to be the correct Criterion
there are some subtleties about it which
I hadn't realized at that time
and these
lead us into interesting territory
so some of the work you did on this was
with a neuroscientist a colleague of
yours Stuart hammeroff who who wrote to
you having read your book yes and and
said that
there are structures in the brain that
would allow for the phenomenon that you
were describing of that book
yes I guess my question is is does this
emergence of Consciousness only happen
in the brain and do we need the
structures that we find in the brain for
that to happen or is it a phenomenon
that we're going to observe in other
parts of nature oh
stands for object objective reduction
that means the reduction of the quantum
State as an objective process
but it's a acronym which is deliberate
namely it spells or
so it means rather than having this and
this simultaneously occurring
one or the other happens so it means or
and the orc parts means orchestrated
that's the vagus part we don't really
know what orchestrated means but somehow
the collapse of the wave function has to
be under control in a way and that's
presumably how how the brain
sorts it all out I mean there's a lot of
unknown about it and the scheme has
certainly evolved very considerably
since the original ideas
microtubules were a revelation to me
because I didn't know anything about
them and I knew I learned a little bit
about nerve propagation and realized it
was
Way Off the Mark if you wanted to have
something
which could preserve coherence at the
level you would need here and the way
that I understood nerve prop was a
propagation operated it would disturb
the environment in a completely
uncontrollable way no way of preserving
the coherence so when Stewart wrote to
me and informed me about microtubules I
thought that sound much more promising
there is you could imagine at least
that there was a preservation of
coherence at the level that maybe
okay there's a lot more to the story
and certainly the story has evolved very
considerably largely I think on the
neurobiological side
Stuart has much more
firm ideas about where this happens
for example there's a big problem which
always struck me as a big problem
even when I was writing the empress new
mind and you've got this part at the top
this cerebrum and then this part back
underneath called the cerebellum
and
even at that time I didn't realize I
didn't know I don't think science
scientific Community knew that the
cerebellum has more neurons in it than
the cerebrum
if you're just looking at a complicated
network of something or other why is the
cerebellum completely unconscious
whereas it's got more cells in it and
they're all wow that also in a more what
you might call Sensible way that's just
to say controlling the right arm is not
done on the left as the cerebrum does
you have this crazy looking organization
obviously done for some deep reason that
we don't fully understand because the
cerebrum doesn't worry about that
cerebellum I mean cerebellum doesn't
worry about it your left hand controls
the left hand and the right hand
controls the left hand it does what you
might think you're designing a computer
to operate things
whereas
what's the difference well a difference
which is what Stuart is concentrating on
is these things called pyramidal cells a
particular type of cell
which is not found in the cerebellum and
Stewart thinks that's where
Consciousness is really operating and
he's worked these things up much more
detail now than we had in those days
I wonder what you make of quantum
Computing now that it's becoming a
reality it was in the past the
speculation of whether we could be
we could build quantum computers now it
seems that we can
does that affect the way that we might
think Consciousness arising in non-human
entities
not really you see the term quantum
computers has changed rather since when
I first heard about them but basically
there is no attempt to do something
wasn't which isn't a computation in the
ordinary sense of the word you may want
to speed things up do them faster you
have some class of problem
which you can speed up using these
Quantum computed devices but they're not
using the collapse of the wave function
a quantum computer as that term is used
now is still an algorithmic device
now
this means that we need to go beyond
what's called a quantum computer if we
are going to harness the reduction of
the state as something which is useful
to us
that's way off what we know how to do
now
another philosophical question that sort
of arises from from physics is can
something come from nothing
and for many years the standard
cosmological model was answering that
question affirmatively the Big Bang was
supposed to be that it was a creation
out of out of nothingness
but you have changed your mind on this
and you seem to be returning back to the
idea of this steady state Eternal
Universe can you tell us about
what do you think now and what made you
change your mind yes
I don't think they've
we see this true that when I first
seriously got interested in cosmology
it was through the steady state model
and it it came about for perfectly good
reasons
because the age of the universe seemed
to be less than the age of public
globular clusters and that needed an
explanation well the steady-state model
was one route to go it turned out there
was a mistake in people confusing Soviet
variable stars with the wrong ones but
the idea of estate my brother appeal to
me I think uh
when the microwave background was
discovered and it seemed that the Big
Bang really was there
Dennis Sharma who was my mentor very
much
um changed he I had a lot of respect for
him it changed his mind and he went
around lecturing to say I was wrong
previously
um
and so I went along with that too
but nevertheless the background of the
steady state model I think was something
that's appealed to me it wasn't the
reason for it using introducing CCC the
re the reason for introducing that's
conformal cyclic cosmology reason for
introducing that idea
came about from
what regarded me as a huge paradox
um you see I had my Singularity theorem
which eventually won the Nobel Prize and
Stephen Hawking picked up on this and
use the same sorts of arguments and
developed them and improved upon the
arguments and developed them so is that
you could apply them to the Big Bang
but it was all saying so well this is
part of one story and the argument was
normally made that the answer to that
story is quantum gravity you have
combined gravitation with quantum
mechanics
but that never seemed to make sense when
I say never seemed to make sense it
seemed to me that it had to be a very
peculiar Theory
which wasn't an ordinary quantum
mechanics which had to be asymmetrical
in time because the singularities in the
future in black holes
are completely different in structure
from the ones the one that we know
directly naming the big bang and this
has to do with the gravitational degrees
of freedom being completely canceled out
completely
reduced to zero in the Big Bang
and I first of all I just sort of
postulated that
but then one of my graduate students
I can't remember whether he was still a
graduate student at the time this is
Paul Todd
and Paul Todd had a different way of
saying how you characterize the initial
State you just don't say well the
gravitational degrees of freedom is zero
you say that the Big Bang can be
stretched out to be something nice and
smooth
um and that was a better way of talking
about it but it led me to think well
you stretch out the Big Bang to make it
nice and smooth you can squash down the
infinity to make it nice and smooth and
when you think about it
they seem very different the Big Bang is
hugely dense usually hot
the remote future is few hugely rarified
usually cold
as bad as opposite as you might think
but if you squash it down by this
conformal squashing
temperature goes up density goes up
stretch out the Big Bang temperature
goes down density goes down they see
brother similar so I've postulated the
idea
that the Big Bang
is the continuation of the remote future
of a previous Elm
as I called them and that
makes sense of lots of things
that are puzzling in the Big Bang the
uniformity is necessary because of the
uniformity of a remote future
there's a thing called inflation
which is current part of current
cosmology which is always worried me
it's in the very very us artificial idea
you need an exponential expansion in the
reading City hiding in the Big Bang
which seemed to be artificially put
there but if you've already got an
exponential expansion which is the
previous eons exponential expansion
maybe that will do for you the job that
inflation is supposed to do so there
were various things which seemed to fit
together
it was not so much the steady state
philosophy I think I've felt sympathetic
towards that kind of view but how much
of a driving force it was
in formulating CCC I'm not sure
and is this supposed to be the cycles of
the same universe or are we talking
about different as it were a universe
has been I'm using the term Eon to
discuss that's why I'm saying not
Universe you see some people say it's a
previous universe but you see it's not a
different universe in the sense of it's
being separate and different it's
connected because there are effects
which come through I mean that's the
whole story
I know I went a long time lecturing to
people thinking that I would never
be able to be proved wrong you see but
then I thought well there are signals
that could get through they should be
there
and in work I've done with colleagues we
do seem to see such signals and we're
having an awful lot of trouble
convincing the cosmological community
that these signals are really there but
the evidence is pretty strong now that
there are
signals which seem to propagate through
from one Eon to the next
my final question what's the one problem
in theoretical physics that still
puzzles you the most and one that you
would like to understand better
well I think it
let me say the second most is the trying
to get the equations to work
to go from money on to the next there
are some issues that need to be sorted
out there I mean the general picture is
there and the observations don't depend
very much on a detailed Theory to tell
you how to join one to the next and find
equations which do that
but that's not the major problem the
major problem is the collapse the wave
function we need a theory
and at the moment
we don't even have direct observations
there are several experiments proposed
or having been
in action for a while
to try and test to see whether
the gravitational contention about when
the collapse happens actually does
happen
spontaneously do we see that
and the detailed theory of how that
comes about
that's the major missing there in the
physics I think but but it's
observationally missing too we don't we
don't see directly this effect in any
experiment which is done and it's all
mixed up with the coherence and then you
don't know what's going on so so it's
difficult question Roger Penrose thank
you very much thank you